and yeah man life is [ __ ] good dude
life is [ __ ] good it is very nice i
was telling dove earlier today that like
i was just walking around my
neighborhood and i was like i could live
in a beautiful neighborhood like do you
remember that story i told you when i
was on percocet and i like told the girl
i loved her and the colors
yeah it was just everything was so
beautiful like that's how i felt this
morning walking my dog like without the
the stress
of knowing that i had to
record a special and knock it out and
make sure every joke was right and make
sure you know i was getting up and and
finding every loose end and make sure i
was tying it like to just wake up and go
we're just going to go do a pod later
today
at a certain time and then we're two
hours late already on the podcast
because i was trying to [ __ ] two
actually yeah we're two days sorry about
that everybody at home but just like
is this what normal people do every day
is they just have a life of they enjoy
their neighborhood yes no i think
overall your stress from after the last
show it's just completely different like
really yeah you went from like ah
there's peace and then the next day you
were crazy i was back on it or what no
wait wait wait wait what happened what
happened i mean the next day we was
going for it oh we were partying yeah
yeah
because after day one yeah i felt such a
[ __ ] calm
you know like it was it was amazing it
was like i was i was more
anxious for
not entirely
yeah we'll get into it
but
i was more nervous for the shows in san
diego than i was for the day two of
special taping yeah why is that no clue
i think the show's in san diego i'm like
okay i still want to make these tweaks
and adjustments and get the special
right and this is going to be my last
run through where i could see if the
jokes and the timing and the order and
everything works well
and then day two
you know i was like i was like okay i
think i think we got it let's just see
what happens and then uh
we did day two and we're like oh yeah we
got on day two yeah yeah yeah yeah
sorry day one
[Laughter]
look it's looking like it's gonna be
monday's shows yeah they make it but um
but yeah just huge thank you to
everybody and just walking around with
the [ __ ] i i saw a guy on my block
watching porn uh just sitting down on
the street nice and uh it was [ __ ]
amazing it was a he was an old indian
man watching porn on his cell phone and
he had his headphones in and he thought
that he was listening to it on his
headphones
and it was just
blaring out of his foot it was like
super loud like moaning like when you're
trying to do the prank yeah yeah yeah
right just
and the guys and the guy's looking at
his phone like this and he doesn't want
people to think he's watching porn so
he's like looking at like astutely like
he's like watching
something like that he's like okay and i
just walked by and i just hear like it
was distinctly asian it was oh
south asian was it india i think i think
it might have been south africa
yeah actually i've never seen indian
porn
are they allowed to i have no clue have
you guys seen indian porn
i mean
oh no that's that's muslim yeah no yeah
whoa just indian comments on oh yeah
they're all awesome yeah that's because
they don't have porn ah
i mean they're all comments bro yeah
they go crazy on the comments i love it
though in the morning i mean they talk
about his stress but he's like
our neighborhood so it's so beautiful
and then it's he's talking about
watching someone uh watching porn and
then an hour later we're talking about
brunch spots and i'm like talking about
one of my favorite spots he's like no no
i went there the other night cat-sized
rats
yeah yeah yeah yeah just there's rats
but it's okay
that's nice
yeah character oh al showing me a video
of two people just just having sex on
the metro yeah that's metro that's love
it's love this is not
guys this is beautiful you have to let
these things romance why are you against
romance guys dude i was walking smiling
i was walking down the street smiling
not looking at my dog like if you don't
take a [ __ ] already so i can get back
there and finish this [ __ ] special
like everything was an inconvenience
because we needed to do the special yeah
and now that we have that part of it
done obviously we gotta you know edit
and and you know really kind of build
out what the special's gonna be in post
but
having that part done is um
i don't want to call it an achievement
yet because we haven't made it yeah the
special job ain't finished the job ain't
done on some real kobe show the job
ain't done
but
there was a part of the job that we had
far less control of right like you walk
into a room of a thousand people you
don't know what anybody's gonna do you
don't know who's gonna yell out you
don't know if i'm gonna say the line
writer if i'm gonna mess up a line or do
these things like we don't know right
and
at least in the edit it's like we get to
decide if we take a joke or move it over
here or cut the joke out or something
like now now it's basically man hours
yeah now we're building the pyramids
it's gonna take a while yeah but it's up
to us how many hours we want to sit in
the [ __ ] booth the raw material is
there yes yeah yeah i mean how do you
guys feel what is it like
i'm happy that it went well yeah it felt
like yeah i got everything i wanted to
get from like the shots i had in mind
and
uh yeah i'm like looking forward to the
edit even though i know it's gonna be
it's gonna be a edit yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's gonna be fun because we have a
lot like yeah we have a lot to work with
al came to me afterwards and he's like
and he's like he's like the hardest part
about this is we're gonna have to cut a
lot of stuff that we really love yeah
and that is best case scenario yeah
worst case scenario is we got a stuff
and [ __ ] that we don't want yeah but
it's often harder
to not include something that is like a
really special moment yeah because it
just doesn't fit for whatever reason so
maybe we find another place for i mean
like i think after day two i was like
yeah i think we got another crowd work
special and
[Laughter]
what did you think about mark i was
shocked at how well it went yeah like
going into it like i don't know i wasn't
i was i personally wasn't like overly
stressed i was like just a regular
amount of stress right which i don't
like the feeling of yeah because like i
don't know i'm walking in i was like
well i hope this set looks good like i
hope the all the stuff that i wasn't
even like really in touch with
i just hope that stuff is good i hope
the dp is good and he turned out to be
amazing yeah i just i just hope that
this [ __ ] worked out and it did so i
don't know that regard like walking into
this thing and just having all these
other people that were like good at
their job making stuff happen i'm like
oh it's a lot easier than doing it with
just four people yeah
it is interesting going into these
things because like
i don't think there's a skepticism of of
us as a team or as a unit but since we
don't operate like a production company
there is always going to be some
skepticism about like the skill
right like when you hire a production
company you assume they know what's
going on we don't even know the words
for a lot of things like there's this
thing called a steady cam right which is
there's a thing called a steady cam
which is it basically allows a cameraman
to like move around with the camera
being uh steady the whole time right
it's stabilized it's stabilized right so
you don't have the shaking or anything
so the guy can really literally run and
i guess it's you know fixated on like
some like gyros or something like that
yeah so basically the camera never moves
uh
al and i call it the handycam the whole
time
and it's been used in cinema and tv for
decades yeah it's like it's a handicap i
believe you because you put it in my
head and i couldn't get it out he
couldn't get out i started calling
and then he just kept calling
handicapped and like he's not gonna know
what i mean unless i say handycam so we
just call i think we're calling a
handicap
they were they were correcting you for
the first three or four then after a
while really these professional like
videographers were like yeah the
handycam
[Laughter]
but yeah so exactly so we're a little
bit rough around the edges but we know
what we want the thrust oh my god the
thrust the truss we don't know what it
is the part of the stage that comes out
we're just making up words for all this
[ __ ] but what is cool was a cool
experience is like
at first maybe there being a little bit
of skepticism and then
when the vision starts to be more clear
for everybody right when they like start
to see the suggestions that we're making
and then see these things happen and you
see
you know like uh what it looks like when
the curtains open i don't want to lose
too much stuff but like also seeing the
people realize what they're a part of
and then them get excited by it because
these guys are production guys they work
on tons of productions you know what i
mean you work on [ __ ] hannah montana
you might not be excited about that yeah
and it's really cool for me to like look
at someone who's been in production for
a decade and then they feel like they're
actually part of something that's really
exciting and there's something that
they're proud of yeah and i'm not saying
that they put more effort in but it
seems like they really wanted to go well
like that they're making like
suggestions for creative moves and like
that could really help the
like help the special and like we'll
have a conversation with them like we
always talk you know amongst the team
it's like best idea wins we don't have
any idea we don't have any ego when it
comes to the best idea and you get
people offering some [ __ ] up it was
really cool yeah it was really [ __ ]
cool man
dove how'd you feel about it
it was great and you couldn't see it
from where we were in the control room
like you're seeing the screen with all
eight cameras up at the same time and
when you watch it in that way
you're watching the special it looks
amazing so yeah yeah yeah you guys are
in for something yeah and how did you
feel after all the shows when we were
just you know hanging out going out and
stuff did you feel like you were having
fun in austin or no great time right you
learned a lot about me
a lot of loans aren't about you
dubbed a lot of alone time in austin i
guess you could say like i have alone
time yeah when were you alone
when was he alone just after the shows
you know instead of having companionship
he was uh he was like oh you had
companionship you just didn't close
anything
that's a new stage in my life where yeah
open it up
you know how many times devas said to me
like the last month like i got touched
over the pants
he's bragging about touching over he's
regressing back to middle school
it used to be a closer dog what does
this touch over the pants so this is a
new stage look at me she was like
rubbing me over my pants and i couldn't
do it it sounded like before you got
married
yo that was a dry home king bro we need
one loser in the crew okay
[ __ ] left it right now
from the same girl but still
no it's not that it's i'm growing up but
it was one of these things where it's
like you can't people are like oh you're
on the road you're picking up girls from
the show you're taking them down i'm
like no no the girls still look at me
like all right you hooked me in but now
you look like a normal nice guy that i
would like to date and so you're going
to wait you're not going to does excuse
like whenever a girl doesn't give any
[ __ ] it's like she likes me too much
right
like how do you even convince yourself
that's next-level confidence
it
[Applause]